so she created project Maryland in 2019
and since then she has helped tens of
thousands of women with safe menstrual
Health practices joining us this morning
Wendy schweigart you got it you got it
she's the founder of this wonderful
local non-profit in just a few years
Wendy you have made such a tremendous uh
impact here on the valley for folks who
have not heard of project Maryland talk
a little bit about your mission and what
you do so project Maryland was founded I
founded April of 2019 after I read an
article about period poverty in a
magazine two and five people who have a
period can't afford period supplies
every given year due to lack of income
that's a huge two in five two and five
but also one in four girls miss school
every month for not having proper period
supplies and so we founded project
Maryland was my mom we lost her to
cancer in 2011 and so we dedicate our
mission of giving women dignity back to
her she passed away she said she had
never made an impact and it's just
important for everyone to know just by
being here and by being you yeah made an
impact so this is her Legacy you have
created this incredible organization to
help so many women
um and and you mentioned younger girls
um that certainly you know periods are
happening younger and younger and if
they're not able to get those supplies
that's tough so you have a partnership
now and you're working with CCSD talk
about that we are we are we're super
excited we have partnered with the Clark
County School District to provide a
beginner period kit to all of their
girls in the fifth grade so in the fifth
grade the Clark County School District
has a growth and development class okay
where they talk about periods and you
know all things about you know puberty
and all those things like I mean I heard
here in southern Nevada and you know
that was the first time I heard about
periods oh boy right and so the Clark
County School District shared with me
that they had a vendor for a while
providing
um you know a couple pads and whatnot
and they stopped doing it so they said
would you like to help and I said
absolutely because when you think about
it having your period for anyone is can
be traumatic and getting and getting a
period stain on your pants as an adult
can be embarrassing but if you get when
you're young if you get a period mark on
your pants in the fifth grade or anytime
you know as a young person you yeah
certainly would never forget and
certainly don't want to have to
experience so how can Folks at home help
you so that we can make this a bigger
bigger thing right so like I said we
partner with Clark County School
District we are making these period kits
five pads five liners
um going to be distributed on April 28th
I hate to open this up you can open it
do it you know open it up what I really
love about these is we were able to
Source girl pads so what those are is a
little bit of a smaller pad for smaller
but the right size right because we want
to make these intentional our purpose is
to make everything intentional it's
something that we give to them because
we care about them all our clients it's
not just a bag of junk we threw together
for you so yes so we are also fortunate
for the month of March to be chosen by
the Helms helps Foundation they are
matching donations for the month of
March up to a total of twenty thousand
dollars excellent so if you can visit
projectmaryland.com and make us a
donation for the month of March your
donation will be doubled by the homes
help Foundation excellent Wendy we can
talk all day we are out of time but go
to the project Maryland website you can
help out you can even volunteer I know
she needs them I've helped stuff these
bags as well so Wendy thanks for waking
up early this morning folks at home if
you have any questions we'll put it on
our website but go make that twenty
thousand dollar match they love you
congratulations on your success